[David] I'm happy to announce my new course on Applied Cryptography
Cryptography means secret writing
it goes back to the earliest human desires to keep and share secrets.
In the early days, cryptography was only available to generals and emperors
but today it's used by nearly everyone everyday.
Every time you do a credit card transaction, make a phone call,
use a secure website, you're using cryptography.
In this class we'll start by learning the mathematical foundations behing cryptography.
Then we'll see how to use cryptography to solve problems in computing.
We'll see how to use cryptography to manage passwords
and user accounts, to do secure transactions, to make money
from nothing but numbers, and to do computation
while keeping your data private.
Cryptography is a really fun topic: it's all about making and breaking puzzles.
I hope I'll see you in class.
CS 387: Applied Cryptography. Taught by Professor David Evans.